IT'S TIME TO PLAY
SCANDAL IN THE WIND.
JON WAS MAKING FUN OF BERNIE
SANDERS AT THE COMMERCIAL
BREAK.
>> GIVE ME ALL THE POINTS.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR,
JUST BECAUSE I GARGLE WITH
MILK DUDS, TO MAKE FUN OF MY
VOICE.
AND SINCE YOU BROUGHT UP THE
POINTS I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT I'M BEHIND ON THE SCORE
NATIONALLY BUT IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND IOWA I AM
AHEAD ON POINTS.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF YOU.
>> Chris: THAT'S GOOD.
YOU HAVE GOOD POINTS.
MOVING ON, SINCE THE ADVENT
OF PHOTOGRAPHY POLITICIANS
HAVE BEEN GETTING CAUGHT IN
SCANDALOUS SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS SHAMEFUL PHOTO OF
MARTIN VAN BUREN.
HE HAD GLAUCOMA, DON'T
JUDGE.
BUT BY TALKING YOUR WAY OUT
OF TROUBLE-- WHAT ARE YOU-- WAIT
BERNIE, COME HERE A SECOND,
BERNIE, COME HERE.
BERNIE SANDERS.
>> HOLD ON, FOLKS.
I THINK, THERE IS A
RESEMBLANCE HERE.
>>WHOA.
>>WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
I DON'T SEE IT.
>> Chris: ARE YOU--
(APPLAUSE)
ARE YOU-- WAIT A MINUTE.
>> I HAVE JUST ENOUGH HAIR
AND I'M ALSO EXACTLY BALD
ENOUGH TO BE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: TALKING YOUR WAY
OUT OF TROUBLE IS A
POLITICAL TRADITION.
SO WE HAD OUR @MIDNIGHT
PAPARAZZI CATCH A FEW
CANDIDATES IN COMPROMISING
POSITIONS AND OUR PANEL WILL
DO THEIR DAMAGE CONTROL. FOR
250 POINTS PUT A POSITIVE
SPIN ON THESE RATHER
SALACIOUS PICTURES.
HEATHER, WE WILL START WITH YOU.
YOU WILL BE HILLARY
CLINTON'S SPIN DOCTOR HERE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT YOUR CANDIDATE?
>> ALL RIGHT, AS HILLARY'S
PR HERE I WANT TO SAY THE
TATTOO WASN'T FINISHED. IT IS
SUPPOSED TO SAY
"NICKELBACK RULES: RULE #1, NO
NICKELBACK."
>> OKAY.
SO IT WAS JUST NOT DONE YET.
>> YEAH, NOT DONE.
>> Chris: OKAY, POINTS.
BUT HILLARY DIDN'T STOP WITH
GETTING INK, SHE ALSO WAS --
THERE.
>> OKAY, OKAY.
>> Chris: EXACTLY.
HOW DO YOU GET OUT OF THIS
ONE?
>> WELL, TO BE FAIR, PUTIN
WANTED BAREBACK AND SHE
TALKED HIM DOWN TO HORSEBACK.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
WELL DONE, HEATHER ANNE
CAMPBELL. YOU HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
NAVIGATED A LOT OF
SCANDALS FOR HILLARY
CLINTON.
JON DALY, YOU WILL BE TAKING THE
ROLE OF SPIN DOCTOR ON
BEHALF OF DONALD TRUMP. GOOD
[BLEEP] LUCK.
LET'S SEE IF YOU CAN EXPLAIN
WHAT MR. TRUMP WAS UP TO
HERE, JON DALY, HUH?
WAIT, WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT
THAT?
>> THIS LOOKS BAD BUT AS WE'VE
COVERED, MR. TRUMP HAS HAD
TROUBLE WITH HIS BUSINESSES.
AND ACTUALLY IN THIS HE WAS
JUST LOOKING FOR A CHEAP WAY
TO DEMOLISH TWO CASINOS.
>> Chris: NO!
>> OH YEAH.
>> WOW.
>> Chris: BERNIE SANDERS YOU
ARE UP NEXT.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU WERE CAUGHT
DOING.
WHAT'S THIS BUSINESS?
WHAT IS THAT?
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN WHAT'S
HAPPENING
AND HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THIS?
>> THERE IS NOTHING WRONG
WITH SHARING A BATHTUB WITH
GUY FIERI.
TWO MEN BATHING TOGETHER IS
THE RESPONSIBLE THING TO DO
IN THE MIDDLE OF A WATER
CRISIS.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
>> AND THAT IS ORGANIC
VERMONT SYRUP THAT WE'RE
DRINKING.
>> Chris: OH YOU'RE DOING SYRUP
SHOTS, ALL RIGHT.
NEXT ONE, NEXT ONE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE,
BERNIE SANDERS?
>> LOOK, I AM PROUD OF THAT.
I DON'T HIDE THAT FROM MY
RECORD.
I'M PROUD OF THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT ALL WORKERS
DESERVE A LIVING WAGE.
I FOUGHT FOR THAT.
AND ALSO WOMEN DESERVE EQUAL
PAY WITH MEN!
AND ALSO IF YOU SIMPLY TALK
IN THIS CADENCE AND POINT
YOUR FINGER IN A CERTAIN WAY
YOU WILL FORCE AN AUDIENCE
TO APPLAUD AT A CERTAIN PERIOD
OF TIME.
>> Chris: HE'S REALLY GOOD.